so this team's going to be built on uh
we're going to kick you in the teeth all
right and when you punch us back we're
going to smile at you and when you knock
us down
we're going to get up and on the way up
we're going to bite a kneecap off all
right and we're going to stand up and
then it's going to take two more shots
to knock us down all right and on the
way up we're gonna take your other
kneecap and we're gonna get up and then
it's gonna take three shots to get us
down and when we do we're gonna take
another hunk out of you before
before long we're gonna be the last one
standing all right that's gonna be the
mentality
well jack it sounds good but
unfortunately these young kids nowadays
that's old school talk that's like 85
bears in the 90s and stuff like that
these young kids they're not they don't
have that mentality so for him to come
in and say hey we're going to do this
we're going to do that it's going to be
very difficult for them for him to find
those type of players considering the
young players they don't they just don't
have that as their personality
what are you trying to say they're not
eating eating kneecaps anymore that's
out of the game now man come on jack you
know them young players ain't thinking
about no kneecaps and all that tough guy
stuff man they don't want that and if
you're trying to and for the life of me
if you're trying to develop
a quarterback whether it's stafford or
young quarterback
don't you bring in like a quarterback
guy or a quarterback coach like he was
wasn't he a tight end
i think he was a tight man right he's
definitely not a quarterback friendly
hire
yeah all right well speak speak out you
got to get to the quarterback as you
know it always does it always has a way
of circling back there so they bring in
the old school staff like you're saying
and immediately stafford goes well i'm
out so it's a new gym yeah he don't want
that new coach
in a new quarterback is what you're
going to have in detroit so the question
says this is third and short three rapid
fire ones for you where is the best fit
for matthew stafford what do you think
i say new england i say new england is a
perfect choice for him he can go in
there they have a good defense they're
going to add a couple more guys
they can they can build on the offense
go out and draft the offensive player go
pick up some guys in free agency and
matthew stafford has never been
considered a leader but they don't need
his leadership they need him to throw
the ball and make completions down the
field they have enough leadership they
have bill they have some of those older
veterans on the defensive side of the
ball they have a good offensive line
that can protect them they have a run
game
and bill needs to add another tight end
go get a couple more wide receivers and
spend some money in free agency but i
think matthew stafford could be a
perfect fit there because they don't
need him to come in and galvanize
everybody like brady did they just need
him to complete some passes and not
throw it into the ground like kim does
every other throw
so belichick has a long history of only
paying for players if they're on a cheap
discount this would not exactly be that
is this an exception to that rule
well i would look at matt and say hey
can we redo your deal can we give you a
brand new two-year deal and maybe give
him two years at 20 million per and if
he does xyz then he gets a 5 million
dollar bonus another 2 million bonus
another 2 million bonus and he can get
up to 30 million it but you don't care
about paying that money if you're 12 and
four
you know what i'm saying that you're
number one on afc in the afc east it
just doesn't matter but i think that
that has to be a strong consideration
you got to spend money in order to get
good players or you're going to continue
to go out there with that crap that you
had this year
he might be at the point of his career
where he's ready to take a little
discount in order to try to win like i i
could definitely see that
dan orlowski who's very close with them
these are the three that he threw out
i'm going to guess they're the three he
threw out because he knows
indy san francisco and denver don't
sleep on elway in this one elway may get
sneaky and come up and try to get
stafford so i'll leave you with those
three to think about but i really think
all of them are in it maybe even new
orleans i mean there's a lot of
quarterback needy situations houston's
going to become quarterback needy miami
maybe even who knows what they're
thinking with to it right now let's get
to the second one desean watson as we're
talking about houston he will be playing
where come next fall
in houston because if i'm nick caserio
he used to be with the patriots i don't
care if i have to give him a piece of
the team i'm doing everything i can you
can't let him go you cannot let him walk
out the door i don't care if he needs a
trainer if he needs this if he needs a
personal chauffeur i'm giving deshaun
watson whatever he needs he's a great
kid he's been humble and it was my fault
as an organization that i did not allow
him to get involved in a head coaching
search
i would give him whatever he wants but
there's no way i'm letting him go out of
houston they'll never ever ever find a
quarterback with that level of talent
ever to come and play in houston
it brings up the aaron rod it almost
circles me back to the aaron rodgers
thing like if if aaron rodgers is
getting no say in the draft pick and
they're drafting his replacement no
saying the head coach and they're
bringing in whoever like what why does
watson think that he's gonna be able to
get all of that same stuff too you know
it's like me it's it's almost like the
the game's evolving and the players know
that they're this important and they
need this kind of say but you have so
many old school minds that are still
making decisions in the nfl and they're
just so stuck in their old ways
and and to me there's nothing more
personifies that better than the houston
texans that's just the most old school
just cannot get out of what it was and
not evolve to what it is franchises ever
i mean it's ugly i i think he's out i i
don't know i don't know if there's
anything houston can do at this point to
keep him he's he's gone so public and
doubled and tripled down time and time
again about getting out of there
i don't see a scenario where he goes
back i think it's jets or miami i really
do yeah he's doing it's just in miami
yeah and if you're mine so we'll go with
that i'm go ahead go ahead rod can you
yeah i'm just saying if i'm miami i
definitely look if i have an opportunity
to get him i definitely look to upgrade
because
if if they had him this year
and they had some injuries at the wide
receiver position
dude they
just imagine if miami had desean watson
it would have really been ugly and
who knows it could have been those mommy
dolphins winning that afc east you just
don't know
that's how good he is i i completely
agree with you this year but if you get
watson you're being that thing for the
next decade and can you imagine miami be
in a cool football town too i mean that
would be that would really be sharp that
would be a cool like south beach blowing
up as a football town would really be
cool all right the third one eric b
enemy if you were eric bienemy where
would you want to go what's the perfect
job for the enemy right now
i think the perfect job for the enemy is
to stay where he's at this year
absolutely stay where he's at don't go
to houston that's like we like we just
talked about that's a bad choice i don't
know if there's any other head coaching
jobs available right now at this point
in time but if i was if i were eric the
enemy i would stay exactly where i'm at
they're still teams are gonna lose four
or five teams they're gonna be four guys
getting fired and he's gonna come up and
have an opportunity for another head
coaching job if i were him and i know
people say well if you're an
african-american if you're a black man
there's no you shouldn't pass up an
opportunity to be a head coach
yeah maybe you shouldn't but you should
in this case because you're only going
to probably get a couple years because
you're going to lose if you go to
houston so i i would suggest that eric
the enemy my former teammate he's stay
right where he's at and then just see
what happens next year
he's going to get a chance to be a part
of a dynasty with the chiefs like you
know probably we're going to talk about
forever right and and you know i nobody
that i've ever talked to feels like
there's going to be any regression from
kansas city next year
there may be better than they are this
year that's what we saw from last year
to this why not next or even better than
that and so he probably gets his pick
but i mean we said this last year about
the enemy man it's like we we said last
year he's going to get his pick of the
litter when it comes to all these jobs
and they go hire a bunch of nobodies a
bunch of guys yeah like you haven't
heard of most of these guys that are
getting the look before being like i
wonder if the fact that he's still in
the super bowl chase and can't go
interview time and time like does that
have something to do with it like this
makes no sense to me that he's not you
know number one every single time when
it when head coaching jobs pop open it
makes no sense
i think a lot of people they they may
look at eric benjamin says how hard is
it to coach patrick mahomes
and maybe that's working against him
other than his skin color because i
don't know if you said it or if somebody
else said it but i'm saying it if he
were white he would have a head coaching
job he would have that opportunity
and it wouldn't it wouldn't it's just
sad and it hurts
it hurts me as a former player because
you know we're good enough for you to
use our body but we're not good enough
for you to use our mind and like i was
trying to tell coach dungey and mike
taurico when i were on with them on
pftpm some weeks ago i said in order for
us to we have to have ownership and the
nfl has to do a better job of creating a
couple org franchises so we can go in
there and buy them and so we could be
the owners african americans there's
this is the nfl
over 75 of guys are black yet we don't
have any ownership representing us so
what are we going to do we're going to
stand in line and beg please give us a
job please give us a job and that's
basically what's going on we're sitting
here we're qualified we're smart we're
successful but yet you still won't give
us jobs and it's it's just it's hurtful
man to wake up every single day
you're grinding you're trying to be the
best you can be you know what you bring
for an organization yet you have
somebody that never even gave you an
opportunity looking down on you and
telling you that you're not good enough
that hurts that hurts and that's why you
see so much fire from black men because
it hurts being told that you're not good
enough that you're not smart enough it
hurts not getting those opportunities
jack
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports